so good evening
today we add an important chapter in our
fight against covet 19.
we took the decision to make available
for european citizens
the first covet 19 vaccine
we granted conditional market
authorization to the vaccine
produced by biontech and pfizer
the european medicine agency assessed
this vaccine thoroughly
and it concluded that it is safe and
effective against
covet 19. based on this scientific
assessment we proceeded to authorize it
for the european union market
as we have promised this vaccine will be
available for all
eu countries at the same time
on the same conditions the first batches
of this vaccine
will be shipped from pfizer's
manufacturing site
here in belgium within the next days
and i've always said during this
pandemic
that we are in this together
so vaccination can start at the same
time
during the european union vaccination
days
on december 27th 28th and 29th
this is a very good way to end this
difficult
year and to finally start turning the
page
on covet 19. this
is our first vaccine more will be
approved soon
if they prove to be safe and effective
emma will issue its opinion on the
second
vaccine that of moderna on the 6th
of january and while we deliver vaccines
for europeans
we also help secure them for the rest of
the world
team europe is the largest contributor
to the covex facility with over
million euros for producing vaccines for
the low and middle income countries
and finally allow me to say how
proud i am that the first covet vex
covered 19 vaccine available in europe
is a true product of european innovation
so biontech has received more than 9
million euros
of eu research funding over the past
decade
to develop these really ground breaking
technologies
and it secured a 100 million euro
loan from the european investment bank
that is backed
by the european union in june
this helped expand its manufacturing
capacities and supply
the vaccine quickly worldwide and
this is a true european success story
so thank you so much
you